[Music]
what's up guys i'm kitty hd here oh okay
what's up guys uh we're out here in
sunny warm
much warmer than the east uh hawthorne
california and we're out here for
the tesla model y event and i say we
because it's you and i but it's i'm out
here we're out here so for the like four
of you who don't know uh model y is
going to be the fourth in tesla's s3 x y
lineup so it kind of completes it so
model s and model x are the big the big
car and the big suv they're more premium
they're more higher priced
and then there's the model 3 which
you're kind of starting to see
everywhere especially in the us
it's a smaller slightly lower priced at
the lowest price they have car
and so model y is going to be
essentially an suv version of model 3.
so this event out here in beautiful
hawthorne why i'm here this is the big
reveal this is where they're finally
going to show us the design
the specs
and the price and maybe they'll start
taking pre-orders or something who knows
maybe uh maybe a surprise or two also
you could tell by the reflection i don't
know how casey and peter and all you
guys vlog with this 1dx this is a
gigantic camera but uh
we'll get to it
i actually really wish
i really wish i had a switch pod right
about now so some of you may be
wondering why model y
why model y is even a big deal at all or
even if it is i think it is i think
model y could end up being a bigger
seller than the model 3.
and it's because i mean we've seen model
3 sort of rise up in the charts of
best-selling cars over the past couple
months that it's been out
but the best-selling suvs especially in
the us the best-selling suvs are
constantly way outselling the
best-selling cars
so i think model y has a potential to be
a much bigger seller than even model 3.
and so there it is one of the very few
tech products of the past year that
didn't leak so this is your first public
look at the tesla model y so my first
reaction to seeing it first rolled up on
stage was uh yep looks about right looks
like a bigger model three a little
taller but you know from this front
angle on stage very familiar very
similar and the specs of course are
similar too so it's going to be 230
miles with standard up to 300 mile range
with the long range version and then you
can see the acceleration number is
pretty modest if you ask me if you're
not getting the performance version but
of course the performance one is zippy
at 3.5 seconds 0-60 and the price range
and release dates are all here
it's going to start at 39 000 but
similar to model 3 they're not going to
be making that base model cheapest
version right off the bat they're going
to make the higher end more margin
filling models starting in fall 2020
then the base model at 39 000 will come
by 2021. also you may have noticed when
they got that car up on stage
uh seven people got out of it so tesla
is saying model y is a seven seater with
three rows of seats
that is something i had to see in person
because that's uh it doesn't look that
much bigger than model three but that's
exactly what i did so when elon was done
on stage we got to go outside and see it
in person a bit more for ourselves go
for a test ride and take a closer look
now seeing it outside and driving on a
different light basically the more
angles i see it from the more i see it
as basically a hybrid in design between
the model x and the model three it's
like the two of them had a baby or
something and really it's mostly model
three since it's sharing parts with it
but with a few differences so one it's
bigger than model three that's the
obvious one
two there's an all glass panoramic roof
now which looked really cool and
seamless but was literally impossible to
get footage of tonight
three the ride height is a little higher
and that's on purpose so you sit a
little higher in the same seats in this
crossover than you would in the model
three
four i think the front trunk should be a
bit deeper as well that is me
speculating uh they didn't let anyone
open the front trunk or rear trunk but
it looks like that should be the case
and five speaking of trunks the
hatchback so it is now an automatic
lifting rear lift gate that is great for
cargo i love the model s hatchback uh
i've had all four tires in the back of
my car the other day so i'm happy to see
that that's gonna be great for space
and then number six with all that extra
space there is a third row option now
like we saw
seeing it in person it looks extremely
cramped and my gut reaction is i don't
recommend it if you need three rows
worth of people on the regular get a
bigger car like a model x type of size
because if you do put people on the
third row yeah you better hope they're
either smaller or much younger because
the legroom and headroom seem to be both
extremely limited model x has more space
of course
and number seven something i found
really interesting so if you look at the
parts where there is normally chrome on
the model three so the door handles the
window trim the mirror pieces where it's
normally really shiny all of these
pieces on the model y as you can see our
sort of a satin matte black color and it
turns out that's the way it's going to
be there are no shiny chrome pieces on
this car it's like a factory chrome
delete so you don't have to get your car
wrapped to get rid of the chrome anymore
so i think that's pretty sweet not a lot
of people notice that and that's mainly
it so i mean you know i got my 30 second
test drive like everyone else who waited
it was pitch black the footage was
almost useless but hey i got to ride in
it um and one of the angles that you
actually don't get to see as much in a
lot of the videos you're going to start
to see is the back of the car like the
butt of it to me it kind of looks like a
model 3 with the lights but then with
the tall shape of the model x but no
spoiler so again very hybrid like and
the interior
as far as steering wheel and display and
the seats and everything is exactly the
same as the model 3. so basically if you
like the model 3's looks you'll like
this if you didn't like the model 3's
looks then this is going to change your
mind or anything but that's about it i
mean all the time i got to spend with
model y was pretty brief hopefully we
get to spend more time with it soon
maybe we can do an autofocus episode in
the daylight sometime that would be sick
also bonus i got to spend a hot minute
with the 2020 roadster first time i've
ever seen the car in person actually and
sweet
baby jesus that car looks incredible i
want it to exist so bad right now
so many things about it like the carbon
fiber and the wheels the rear diffuser
the screens on the inside the seats the
color the arrow the bodywork everything
so hot uh i really hope it's on time
that car is sick
anyway that's been it guys hope you
enjoyed your first look at model y the
affordable slightly larger model 3 with
a third row option and a hatchback
liftgate i do i really do think it will
sell more than the model 3 because of
the utility but only time will tell so
stay tuned for more videos either way
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one peace
[Music]
[Music]